Salut. Vous avez vu en ce moment sur les chaînes
de PewDiePie, de Super Konar, de Pierre Croce, d'Absol et de pleins d'autres
que ça déconne à pleins tubes sur Youtube
Jeu de mots
Alors, si vous êtes abonnés à la chaîne
Pensez à cliquer sur la petite cloche
à côté de l'abonnement pour activer les notifications
ça permettra que mes nouvelles vidéos vous apparaissent parfois en suggestions
sinon, vous pourriez les rater
C'est pas tant pour cette année d'ailleurs que pour l'année prochaine
mais ça, on y reviendra
Et aujourd'hui, on va parler d'un cheval mentaliste
Générique
Nous sommes fin du 19ème siècle
Il y a un professeur de mathématiques, qui s'appelle Wilhelm Von Osten
qui a fait toute sa vie, qui a pris sa retraite en 1888
Il s'installe à Berlin
Il veut se consacrer à ce qui le passionne le plus en ce moment
c'est la théorie de l'évolution qu'on appelera par la suite le Darwinisme
Il pense sincèrement que les animaux et les êtres humains peuvent communiquer entre eux
et surtout que les animaux sont très intelligents,
beaucoup plus que ce qu'on pense.
Et en même temps, à l'époque, ils avaient pas les lolcats
Il pouvait pas savoir le pauvre...
Passionné de Darwinisme et de maths, il commence à enseigner les mathématiques
à un chat, à un cheval et à un ours
Normal, j'ai envie de te dire, quand t'es à la retraite, tu t'occupes
Pour faire court, grosso modo , le chat, au bout d'une heure, il s'en fout, il se barre
L'ours, c'est pas terrible
Par contre, le cheval, ça a l'air intéressant.
Il se dit : "Ok, je vais enseigner les maths qu'à des chevaux."
Il continue à faire ça, en stimulant ses élèves, on va dire,
à taper avec le sabot pour donner les réponses aux opérations ou aux questions qu'il leur pose.
Et c'est comme ça que Wilhelm Von Osten s'aperçoit que Hans est un petit surdoué.
Hans, c'est un cheval russe qu'il a acquis. Simplement, il déchire.
Il arrive les soustractions, les racines carrés, les additions, les multiplications
Il est au top !
Et c'est pour ça qu'en 1904, Von Osten se fait le plaisir
de faire une petite présentation publique de ses prouesses avec Hans
du moins des prouesses du cheval
où, publiquement, il va lui faire faire des additions, des soustractions...
Il va aller plus loin que ça, il lui fait aussi lire l'heure.
Il aurait eu Facebook à l'époque, ça faisait le buzz
Et c'est cette même année que le psychologue Oskar Pfungst
...
Je ne vais jamais réussir à prononcer son nom de famille.
Alors, on va l'appeler Oskar, par son prénom
Parce que c'est comme ça, aussi, c'est beaucoup plus sympa je trouve.
Donc c'est en 1904 qu'Oskar décide d'étudier un petit peu Hans
qui se fait appeler "Hans le malin" d'ailleurs
C'est la première fois, à ma connaissance, qu'un psychologue entame ce genre de démarche.
Au début, ça se passe très mal
Il faut dire que Von Osten n'aime pas du tout la démarche d'Oskar
Le psychologue se fait même mordre plusieurs fois par le cheval
mais, après, ils trouvent une méthodologie.
Donc, au départ, il essayait juste de l'appâter avec de la nourriture
et puis, il essaye des tests, en fait, qui sont pas forcément sur l'appât de quelque chose
juste des tests normaux, mais plus rigoureux.
Par exemple, pour les additions, il écrit les chiffres sur des cartes et il met les cartes au sol
de manière à ce que, et le cheval, et le propriétaire du cheval Von Osten, et lui-même,
puissent voir les nombres, les chiffres.
Il demande l'addition à Hans, et Hans tape avec son sabot et réponds.
Il y a 98 % de réussite, c'est quand même énorme.
Et là, Oskar essaye une autre méthode
C'est-à-dire que les cartons ne sont vus que par le cheval
et pas par le propriétaire du cheval, par Von Osten.
Et là, on tombe à 6% de réussite seulement.
Le cheval se plante complètement.
Dans le même état d'esprit, quand Van Osten va à l'oreille de Hans pour lui murmurer une addition
d'où le film "L'Homme qui murmurait à l'oreille des chevaux"
Quand Von Osten soufflait l'addition à l'oreille de son cheval
le cheval avait un très fort taux de bonnes réponses.
Mais !
Quand il ne lui soufflait qu'un chiffre
qu'il partait
qu'Oskar, le psychologue, venait souffler le deuxième chiffre et qu'il partait
Von Osten ne connaissait pas le deuxième chiffre
et Oskar ne connaissait pas le premier.
Il n'y avait que le cheval qui connaissait les deux
Et bah là, il se plantait, il se gourait.
Alors certaines personnes médisantes on dit que c'était trafiqué, que c'était truqué.
Mais ce n'est pas ça.
C'est encore plus intéressant que ça.
Durant des années, Von Osten était persuadé d'avoir réussi à communiquer avec la race des équidés.
Mais, il avait juste réussi à communiquer avec lui-même.
Comment ? Parce que le cheval était mentaliste.
Et ouais ! C'est le premier !
Il réagissait simplement aux expressions faciales et au langage corporel de son maître.
Comme il voulait la récompense, il savait qu'il voulait bien faire
il surveillait juste les expressions de Von Osten
C'est-à-dire que si Von Osten ne connaissait pas la réponse à la question qui lui était posé
lui-même ne pouvait pas savoir quelle était la réponse
puisque que c'était sur l'excitation du visage de Von Osten qu'il se basait pour s'arrêter de taper, par exemple.
C'est énorme !
Il était tellement bon que même si ce n'était pas Von Osten qui lui posait la question,
il pouvait réussir
Tout ce qui était important, c'était que la personne qui lui pose la question connaissait elle-même la réponse.
ça a donné un nom à cet effet
Il y a eu d'autres études de faites là-dessus
dont une sur des rats et d'autres sur des étudiants
C'est pas la même chose.
On a appelé ça "L'effet Clever Hans"
qui dit que l'expérimentateur peut influencer inconsciemment, sans le vouloir, le sujet.
Je vais vous mettre toutes mes sources dans la description.
Il y en a une autre qui est intéressante
qui mériterait même une vidéo à part entière
Lisez si vous avez le temps
C'est l'expérience Pygmalion du psychologue Robert Rosenthal de Harvard
qui a été aussi un test sur l'influence de l'expérimentateur sur un sujet
mais là sur des élèves, sur des enfants
et je vous mettrai également un autre lien sur Gary Wells
qui avait une hypothèse également
toujours sur le principe de Clever Hans
que, dans un interrogatoire de police, les policiers pouvaient aussi influencer,
insconsciemment, les victimes, les témoins, les suspects.
Mais sa recherche est plus basée sur les témoins
et c'est ça qui est important.
Au final, l'effet Clever Hans, c'est ce qui a donné un petit peu cette norme
de faire des expériences en doubles aveugles
pour être sûr que l'expérimentateur n'influence pas les résultats.
C'était la dernière vidéo de cette semaine au bureau.
Et tant mieux, parce que là, on entend pleins de travaux à côté
La semaine prochaine, ce sera les vidéos à la maison
à l'ancienne.
La vidéo des familles
J'espère que cette vidéo qui vous faisait découvrir un cheval mentaliste vous a plu
Si c'est le cas, n'oubliez pas, c'est hyper important de mettre un pouce en l'air
Surtout dans ces temps difficiles de Youtube.
S'il y a d'autres histoires de ce style dont vous voulez que je parle
n'hésitez pas à le mettre dans les commentaires
J'aimerai bien avoir votre avis sur ce genre de format.
Peut-être que l'année prochaine, j'aimerai avoir une série comme ça
où je vous fais découvrir des choses, toujours en lien avec le mentalisme
mais un peu plus historique et un peu plus décalé.
Je voudrais votre avis, si vous voulez bien me le donner, c'est très gentil.
Avant la fin de l'année, j'ai également de refaire une vidéo où je mentalise quelqu'un
l'un d'entre vous, l'une d'entre vous
donc je ferais la demande sur l'un des réseaux sociaux
Vous avez tous les liens dans la description de toute manière
Merci toujours d'être là, toujours aussi nombreux
Merci pour ceux qui sous-titrent les vidéos ;-)
Merci pour ceux qui partagent la vidéo
Vous êtes au top !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonnez si c'est pas déjà fait
et le mental vlog, c'est toujours une vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
On approche du bout, on va pas se mentir
Donc rendez-vous demain, à 11h. Ciao !
Ciao !
J'ai dit Ciao !